you too much as oui oui bon papa excusez
moi papa aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur
des glissoires york et l'extension de
chevalerie médiévale warfa pourquoi
personne joue ça hein c'est la classe
rejeter est bon la pro a n'ont put
acquis c'est que ça j'ai entendu du
bruit
ces mets pas un [ __ ] de pas celui-là
il est à moi attention tu m'auras pas où
le duel est engagé le tout j'ai entendu
crier
et ben non on fait un cache cache alors
c'est un joueur expérimenté et bien non
et ça eh bien non ok peut-être jamais
sans ma tête je me levais et je vous
demande un truc de fou via cette lancée
carrément élastique et bien non regardez
mes [ __ ] m'aurait jamais j'ai combien
trop où j'entends bientôt c'est la tête
coupée mais tiens moi j'étais ailleurs a
building up retournement oui mais il a
disparu
cet homme est très agile attention je te
vois au shakedown up retournement choc
oh mon dieu je m'attendais pas du tout à
ce que ça marche tu fait moins le malin
je t'ai vu je t'ai vu tu aussi
apparemment des fêtes
le scandale a le scandale t'es pas
d'accord ça ça veut dire non je suppose
ping team aller à les pirates
attention mon ami pirates les a pas vus
oui j'ai allaité des mémos aussi tu as
un mec j'ai surpris pâle perdu
oh [ __ ] reconstitution de la scène
john où nous devons aller
merde je suis un pirate je marche d'une
manière très viril non mais les mecs
vous prenez à combien la à
qu'est ce qu'ils aient une petite danse
en plus mon perso bon mais c'est une
blague
allez mes légumes à tricot aller non non
c'était quoi ça et c'est vrai pour
captain america ce bouclier est un peu
moins stylé qu'avant je je je dois bien
la corde et oui dans le tas kubota
s'étaient inscrits moeurs avec les mecs
ah bon les mecs encore en vie mais la
regarder comment je peux vendre
tiens mes dents mais je tire dans le tas
mme nul high tone homme qui fait 20
mètres là mais qu'il a arraché un poteau
lumineux dans la rue où ils m'attaquent
avec quoi alors s'est il pas trop à elle
fut tirs au but si tu as un mec j'ai tu
as un mec au mode de ce qui est pratiqué
avec ce fusil c'est qu'il faut option
fumigènes tu tires hop et la opté cacher
derrière lui et personne d'autre bois
vous ne vous marchez pas les parties de
mon corps une par une comme ça ça ne se
fait pas j'ai réussi une fois j'ai
produit de la virilité est avec nous
aujourd'hui
alors va aider notre notre camarade tu
le lait là ok je suis carrément
sacrifier pour lui la prochaine fois je
ne veux pas à mes [ __ ] avec le va
couper des bouchons et de me tuer des
gens comme ça là je peux utiliser le
canon non mais je peux me taper la tête
de super j'arrive pour vous aimez les
diamants mais je m'en fous ça fait style
que c'est moi qui l'ait tué allons seuls
les verts les mecs
tiens il va mourir lui où il va mourir
allait bénéficier [ __ ] mais a aimé
qu'il y ait un côté magali black stars
ok j'ai tué un ennemi à un allié
c'était la manière de dire bonjour ce
barbare dans le tchat
il est avec le mec généralement dans un
jeu quand tu écris ça tu es comme ça
devant ton clavier [ __ ] tu le veux pas
mais non
salut sans problème va se le faire a dit
ça mon gars très fiers de nous je suis
tellement fier que je vais y aller au
point je le faire lui tient [ __ ]
auquel tous ok ça aurait pu marcher moi
je pensais qu'on lui met tout à coup
dans le dos ça allait se passer comme ça
et vous tuer mais bon apparemment il a
une plaque de ciment à la place du dos
vous avez de la chance que l'asp entre
nous sinon je serais venu vous défoncer
aulas je crois qu'il nous a repérés
attention ninja orient où la flèche en
plein dans le pif au le mec mais je cale
deux flèches mais main à la fin nord
qu'est-ce qu'il ya un qu'est ce qui
émerge et u11 d'alliés dans le tas a lui
aussi a rétorqué le chat
oui ma tête renella mois un boom des
bardeaux excuse moi mon combat excuse
moi on est tellement mauvais qu'on se
voie entre nous plus tard hockey aa et
là qu'est ce que je fais
[Musique]
ce gros belle on n'est que trois mais
[ __ ] je crois qu'il nous a vus mais
[ __ ] mais c'est trois mails aussi
agile que le marsupilami cet homme faut
que je remarche 20 km avant de le
trouver mais bon ça va être 20 km
amusant vu la démarche de ce pirate
[Musique]
c'est l'heure de la revanche a les jets
la bannière à gg pas du tout à quoi ça
sert j'ai la vallière toi coutelière rue
bel-air à nous attaquer aux quotas ya en
effet je veux des coups de balai on
assiste à un combat
le chassé qui lui a ravi les campagnes
où es tu te fous oui mais ça amène du
pata positionne seller de tuer tout le
monde
attention combats incroyables alcoba de
merde et la rage et hommes venaient me
focus regardez je suis à manu est en
fête
ok ah non mais il tourne autour merci
apparemment c'est genre de mec qui finit
la partie avec un mal de crâne de dingue
je passe dans l'eau et sous le pont et
hop guet-apens raté non derrière toi
derrière toi est ce qu on est maintenant
dans l'autre sens il n'a pas de chance
cet homme
ils étaient perdus il savait plus quoi
faire on a touché il a crié il ya un
petit creux des entendu un petit cri
très viril un petit os
ô ô mon gars bonjour et permettre à data
place quand même fait quoi toi
attention le troisième ah ah ah ah non
pas lui pas lui je m'en fous j'ai
technique alors il a compris un verre un
bien sans tricher s'te plaît sans
tricher jédir
il m'énerve il m'énerve regarder ma
technique et les deux vont arriver là en
face de l'autre et voilà et d'abord je
vais faire ça avec tout ce qu'elle veut
rien dire d'autre qui arrive là bas je
fais georges et rivière lui et bientôt
la grosse tempête du champ de bataille
c'est génial avec un peu dur je lui
pique lui qu'il allait voilà la pierre
va bloquer la pierre en fait c'était le
saut le saut qui se cacher regardez le
up et bientôt coucous n'étaient pas
prévues
et voilà les gens c'est déjà fin de
cette petite vidéo sur des glaces par
ailleurs j'espère que ça ne sera plus
alors on se retrouve très bientôt sur un
jeu vraiment vraiment fun chat au monde
pis je peux pas m'accrocher la voiture
aubert les mèches peut avoir des
caresses sur le banc